you learn and accompany with it this was
Angela Irizarry before her surgery she
didn't have much energy and couldn't do
the things that three-year-old children
enjoy like run or ride a bike very far
Angela was born with a congenital heart
defect that left her with one ventricle
pumping blood through her body instead
of to one of the most severe forms of
congenital heart disease are a diverse
group of structural anomalies that
result in what's called single ventricle
physiology these are children that are
basically born with half a heart this is
Angela three months after the
groundbreaking operation in August 2011
to graft a new blood vessel made of her
body's own cells to help her heart
function efficiently it was the first
time this operation had been performed
in the United States
it made Angela's heart complete before
when she wants to run with her brother
she could tire is here and now she could
she doesn't want to stop T can keep
going right yes
so she's her oxygen and Lego is very
very good now the Irizarry family's long
journey began in November 2007 when
Angela was born with only one functional
ventricle the hearts to ventricles
collect in pump blood through the body
one sends blood to the lungs where it is
mixed with oxygen the second pumps that
oxygenated blood back to the body's
circulatory system with one ventricle
trying to do the work of two there is
much less oxygen flowing to the body
these children are typically known as
blue babies because they're very
cyanotic because their oxygenated blood
and deoxygenated
is mixed on and so these this this
results in in blue discoloration without
surgical intervention there is a 70%
mortality in the first year of life and
survival to adulthood is very unusual an
order for the surgeon to successfully
rearrange the plumbing it requires the
use of synthetic or man-made materials
specifically requires use of a vascular
graft or conduit and it turns out that
complications arising from the use of
these synthetic materials are a leading
cause of post-operative morbidity and
mortality the synthetic grafts are
susceptible to clotting infection and
rejection all life-threatening
furthermore they can't grow with the
child who must endure repeated
open-heart surgeries to replace the
graft so children can actually outgrow
their operations just the way they can
outgrow their shoes but imagine living
in a world where every time your child
outgrew their shoes they needed to go
back to the operating room and have an
operation dr. Christopher Breuer is a
pediatric surgeon at the Yale School of
Medicine he came to Yale in 2003
determined to make a difference on a
daily basis during my training I would
see problems arise for which we had no
real solutions and because we couldn't
fix these problems I would watch
children die and watch families fall
apart working with fellow Yale cardiac
surgeon Toshi chanooka who had developed
a version of this surgery in Japan and a
team of biomedical engineers from Yale
led by Marc Saltzman the team came up
with a novel idea what if they were able
to construct a vascular graft from the
patient's own cells their hypothesis was
that it would grow with the child and
would not be rejected so the the graft
is made from a fabric of a degradable
polymer the polymers called poly lactic
glycolic acid and it's a polymer that's
well known to be safe in in people it's
been used in medicine for for many many
decades and what was unique here is that
it's it's fashioned into a tube so it
takes the form of a graft and then it's
seeded with cells from the patient
and those are collected from the bone
marrow and and then placed in contact
with this graft and then incubated for a
short period of time before the surgeons
implant it into the into the site
what makes this better than a
conventional synthetic graft is is
really twofold one you're using cells
from the patient and placing them on
this material and what develops then is
a real tissue that's formed from the
patient's own cells so there's no
immunological problems the synthetic
material itself disappears and so
there's nothing left behind to create
any toxic effects so within a few months
after the operation what's left is none
of the polymer and in its place is a
normal blood vessel we set out trying to
create a tissue engineered vascular
graft that we could use instead of using
these synthetic man-made grafts with the
hope that if we could create these from
your own tissues on that they would be
living vascular conduits and would not
have all these problems they'd have a
lower incidence of thromboembolic
complications they'd be less susceptible
to infection and they'd have growth
potential and so far our hypothesis is
proven correct actually these these
grafts do work quite well and do possess
growth potential
you know precluding the need for
additional surgeries in these children
in other words they had naturally
rebuilt a defective heart to make it
complete Breuer and his team believed
they had developed a successful
procedure but convincing the US Food and
Drug Administration that this was safe
and effective took time and patience was
well worth the effort the FDA was very
good to work with
we were both focused on one thing we
wanted to make this trial as safe as
possible and the FDA had
a number of really excellent suggestions
that helped us design a better and safer
study Chris Brewer even let his hair and
beard grow long vowing not to cut them
until FDA approval came in November 2009
it finally did it was terrifying and
exciting at the same time the next task
was finding the first patient Angela
Irizarry and her family came to see dr.
brewer to be evaluated you know we
talked to a number of people but really
felt that the Irizarry family were quite
a special family they were all very
bright and very intelligent they asked
very probing and inappropriate questions
and so it seemed like the right
combination we had the child who would
potentially benefit from this procedure
who met all of my criteria to be
included in the study and we had a
family that understood what this was all
about and you know really understood the
potential risks involved and the
potential benefits and so I felt like I
could really obtain what's called
informed consent what was it like for
you when Angela was sick what were you
feeling
well I'm believing God and I have strong
faith you forgot
send me the baby wait if he sent me the
baby he's gonna send me the Angels took
her her so when we first met Angela um
you know she did have some cyanosis her
her her energy level wasn't really what
you'd expect it to be for for a little
three-year-old so the thought of being
able to perform an operation and have a
child improve improve their oxygenation
level improved their energy level and
have better growth and development you
know was what we were looking for you
know she has her condition but anyway
she's been very healthy you know so I
was I was believed that everything is
gonna be okay I'm trust so much to the
help of the Yale Hospital
Angela's surgery was scheduled for
August 2011 we probably did about 20
practice runs just to get ready for this
and my my lab is probably more like a
like a drag practice than a laboratory
at times where we actually had stop
watches and we were you know trying to
save every second we we could
Angela's surgical team was led by
doctors Breuer and Jean oka and
cardiothoracic surgeon Gary cuff on the
day of the procedure we actually had
things scripted out with times and and
it was you know probably sort of like
managing a play or a television show and
that we had to make sure we could you
know meeting our milestones and
accomplishing things at the same time
and it actually worked out perfectly
within 30 seconds of the surgeon needing
the graft it was they're ready and had
met all of its release criteria so that
the hard work paid off as she recovered
angela was attentively cared for by
doctors and nurses at the Yale New Haven
Children's Hospital she had one
complication an infection which was
successfully treated but kept her in the
hospital for two weeks instead of one
after that
Angela came home to complete her
recovery slowly she began to do things
she couldn't do before before she was
normal but you need to stop limit her
physical activities now she doesn't have
an agreement in November
Angela celebrated her fourth birthday at
home a healthy little girl who showed
all signs of being able to live a normal
life her improvement was really
remarkable the last time I saw her in
clinic come she really was a normal
three-year-old running around and her
mom informed me that for the first time
she can ride a bicycle what about the
future Angela can't go to school for
another year because her immune system
is not completely up to snuff yet but
dr. brewer is hopeful that her body will
adapt yeah I think at the end of the day
I think Angela will will have be a very
normal child you know she's a bright
little girl and with the surgery now I
think her heart function is much
improved and and you know I'd anticipate
that she'll be back in school and
you know graduated from high school and
going on to things beyond my hope for
her is well I think that that the same
for all moms that they can they can do
whatever they want they can grow up and
be good persons and I will love that she
can do you know be a doctor or something
that she can help kids the same way that
they help her for Chris Brewer who
devoted so much of his life to this
mission to save lives
there is great satisfaction so you saved
one little girl's life and you've opened
the way for other people to live longer
better more productive lives how does
that make you feel that's about as good
as it gets
you